[Música]
revista de prensa en directo américa de
france 24 marta moya ya nos acompaña en
el estudio marta buena mañana de
miércoles vamos a abrir la revista de
prensa al diario hablando de un
conflicto que ha resurgido nuevamente
pero que nunca ha desaparecido hablamos
de la guerra en la frontera intermedia y
azerbaiyán en el enclave de nagorno
karabaj a marta una región de probation
armenia pero reconocida
internacionalmente a azerbaiyán entonces
en la última jornada se reanudaron estos
enfrentamientos como recoge esto la
prensa internacional en marta empecemos
por el medio al yazira buenos dias raúl
así es alza será titula armenia y
azerbayán intercambian culpas por los
enfrentamientos fronterizos mortales
todo esto porque las tensiones latentes
de los últimos días sobre todo en el día
de ayer y que se han reanudado en el día
de hoy pues dejan entrever que este
aumento de la tensión
genere temores de una guerra nuevamente
como la que hubo hasta 2020 que es
cuando se firmó este acuerdo de paz con
la mediación de rusia dice que este pues
es la lucha más agresiva desde que a
finales de 2020 con esto con la
mediación de rus se alcanzará una paz
que se ha confirmado totalmente endeble
al yazira recogerlas las declaraciones
del ministro
armenio que dicen que los ataques de
estos últimos días son con artillería
morteros drones y rifles de gran calibre
y que atacan tanto a infraestructura
militar como a infraestructura civil y
dice además que se recoge los
testimonios de azerbaiyán que dice que
no a él o sea no ha impulsado esta
ofensiva sino que responde a las
provocaciones a gran escala que dice de
cardiel marta the gardian hace un
explain air acerca pues de los últimos
acontecimientos y aporta contexto
histórico para entender pues qué está
pasando realmente en la frontera entre
armenia y azerbaiyán por el enclave como
decimos del nagorno karabaj dice porque
ha estallado la tensión entre armenia y
azerbaiyán las potencias mundiales piden
el cese de las hostilidades como
comentabas en el consejo de seguridad de
naciones unidas es el enfrentamiento más
sangriento desde 2020 pero esto pues se
remonta a más de un siglo de tensiones
entre ambos países en 1991 recoge este
explain herdez de gard pues la región
declaró su independencia y ahora mismo
se autogobierna con el apoyo de armenia
y por eso pues azerbayán está atacando a
esta frontera en 2020 antes del acuerdo
de paz azerbaiyán impulsó una guerra de
seis semanas que dejó más de 6.000
muertos y además pues dice pues que en
moscú es el garante del acuerdo y que
entonces envió dos mil soldados para
ejercer como soldados de paz algunos
analistas quieren ver esto pues como un
conflicto entre un conflicto religioso
sí porque armenio pues es de mayoría
cristiana azerbayán de mayoría musulmana
pero los analistas dicen que es
exagerado pues decir esto seguimos con
el tema del día en europa marta y es que
la presidenta de la comisión europea
hablamos de von der layen e pronunció
hoy miércoles el discurso sobre el
estado de la unión donde por supuesto
uno de los temas fue la crisis
energética de cara a este invierno que
se pinta bien frío así es el país titula
la unión europea quiere recaudar más de
140 mil millones con su plan para gravar
los beneficios extraordinarios de las
energéticas
esto es una crónica que hace marías la
cronista la corresponsal perdón de
bruselas del país y dice pues que aparte
de tratarse de varios temas internos del
continente la unión europea o sea está
este debate sobre el estado de la unión
ha estado regido o sea el tema central
ha sido la energía y una sensación de
urgencia lo que ha dominado el discurso
de von der leyen que ha cruzado el
ecuador de su mandato de von der leyen
dice esta cronista pues que es la
presidenta de las crisis haciendo
referencia pues al kobe 19 y ahora la
guerra en ucrania dice pues que estas
palabras de von der leyen una presidenta
conservadora no se podrían haber dado
pues hace un año o más de un año y que
ahora pues se apueste a que las grandes
energéticas repartan estos beneficios
que dice marta la agencia rusa estás la
agencia rusa estás cita a putin y dice
pues que en estos momentos los cortes de
suministro en el north stream no fueron
causados o sea fueron causados perdón
por las sanciones a rusia recoge una
conversación de vladimir putin con el
canciller alemán olaf scholz y dice que
rusia sigue siendo un proveedor
confiable de recursos energéticos y que
cualquier intento de culpar a moscú por
las sanciones pues es cínico para
finalizar marta que dice la revista
'time' la revista 'time' pues viene a
recoger un poco que las sanciones de
rusia o sea las represalias de moscú por
las sanciones contra rusia afectan hasta
un emblema como es la torre eiffel que
dice que a partir del 23 de septiembre
va a tener que apagar sus luces
nocturnas una hora antes
marta muchísimas gracias como siempre
por esta revista de prensa del dedo y
mañana jueves con más pasa más